oh
hey [ __ ] i thought i'd get it in there
before
facebook got all shitty with us you know
what
hey oh my goodness
facebook got all shitty with us
i'm kevin smith hey oh
i was just uh inhaling a little pre-show
courage kids
makes it takes bravery to get up in
front of the world and express your
thoughts
is a revolutionary idea for the internet
expressing one's opinion
if you will uh me and mark bernard
gather weekly
to give you our hot takes and we've got
some magical takes coming for this
week's
magical [ __ ] debut i trust mark that
you watched wandavision by now
i i did i have seen all of the episodes
available to the general public
um that is not to say that i've got some
magic link that's given me all of it
either i've just seen the first two
because i'm not a magical person well
that's true i read some people online
like got to see three episodes and i was
like who's
[ __ ] dick do i gotta suck to get a
third like
i got two like every other plebe in the
on the planet just watching what disney
plus gives us
but then i see some [ __ ] online have
seen episode three already man the 70s
episode
doesn't seem fair not at all
thank you there's my hot take for the
week me and mark didn't get to see
episode three
yeah take care of everybody yeah goodbye
[ __ ] off
um we have that to talk about we have so
much to talk about
thank you for joining us uh for another
episode of fat man beyond
we skipped last week uh because well
there was an insurrection and then
everything got better
and we decided perhaps it's time to talk
about pithy things again so here we are
gathering to talk about the [ __ ] that
matters most to us ladies and gentlemen
how have you been
this week captain um well you know i i
wrote out
civil war ii uh in fine style
they even had t-shirts did you i saw
people in the crowd
like like said it said instead of marvel
it said maga and then it said
civil [ __ ] war and i'm like how can
anyone say like oh this was just
happened all of a sudden they had
[ __ ] t-shirts pre-printed they had
much yes
um scary times however uh you know thank
god
the uh the republic still stands um
now almost by accident and also thanks
to like three or four
really smart [ __ ] people you know we
sit around on this show every week and
we talk about how [ __ ]
amazing batman is even though he's not
[ __ ] real or how [ __ ]
wonderful wanda is even though she's not
real let's take a moment to acknowledge
do you know the name of the cop who like
they made a big deal this week
i i don't remember it yeah the black guy
who was like
no no you don't want this way led them
away
like and then you watch the clip like
once you have that information and see
it again and again
and it's like oh my god like that dude
literally made the difference between
life and death and one of the things
that made the biggest difference was
just a gentle push to that one guy as he
kept going and then suddenly they were
like let's go this way
oh it's like that was something out of a
[ __ ] movie it was so like
you know like remember an animal house
when [ __ ] stork
pushed the dude out of the way and then
grabbed the [ __ ] baton and led the
parade into a
into like an alleyway that's like what
it felt like in real time
so according to our special guest today
uh the fella's name is eugene goodman
who was the officer
um i heard they might be giving him like
a some sort of like medal or whatever
i'm like
[ __ ] a medal give that guy like free
salaries
like everybody tip in and make him the
richest man
in washington like that feels like every
statue should be torn down
and every other one should be eugene
goodman and every other one should be
dolly parton
and if you could do that then everybody
wins everybody would be happy
um yes it was a very inspiring uh heroic
moment man that we got to see
in the uh post uh after after
uh january 6th um
i spent a lot of time
writing uh i've i've been writing clerks
three and i finished it
thank the lord um but
you know when you're writing and you
know how like much you love something
you don't like nothing could take you
away from it i'd rather write than
[ __ ] and eat and i love [ __ ] and
eating not at the same time but
but you know writing allows you to do
don't knock it
don't knock it through but writing
allows you to like
[ __ ] escape create your own reality
writing is wanda vision the plot of
wanda vision
it's my [ __ ] life dude whenever i'm
like oh god the outside world is scary
and i don't like beekeepers
i just come into this room and i [ __ ]
make up a fake world where
i control everything and everything's
better and [ __ ] so
as i was riding clarks three i was
having a blast and then
january 6th happened the only thing that
was like
scary and compelling enough for me to
separate
uh from my material pull my head out of
my ass
and stand there for 48 hours glued to
cnn uh the cbs news channel
um everything just watching like i
watched them
count the electoral votes 50 years old
never did that in my entire [ __ ] life
and this week i was like
this shit's like the mandalorian like i
it became my new programs i was so into
it and whatnot
um you were you able to how did you got
kids like my kid's like 21 so i didn't
have to explain it to her i was like
america
but you got young kids what was your
question
well i mean my my experience experience
was similar to yours in that i was i was
kind of on msnbc
and not twitter i had to disengage from
twitter because
it was either i'm going to start just
lobbing firebombs onto the internet and
that doesn't do anybody any good
and i also don't have any information
which makes that the worst way to be
lobbing firebombs
so yeah it was a lot of msnbc a lot of
cnn and
you know it's funny my son would walk in
every now and again and says what's
happening like is it trump and i would
say well
yeah it's like what did he do now it's
like
it seems like lamented a revolution um
why because he lost like well but people
lose all the time i was like yeah i know
he's like so every time i lose something
i can then
just say it was not real and well
that's where you're wrong kid for any
number of reasons you can't do that
um but yeah it's it's luckily again i
don't have like
a 10 year old who doesn't quite
understand the world but even still like
16
it's hard to find a frame of reference
for why are they trying to sack the
capital
and to have that answer be a guy lost an
election
i think about like when i was a kid when
i was in high school like the biggest
thing i believe that happened newsworthy
event
was uh the challenger like exploding and
you know like even then
your parents your teachers were trying
to like
walk you through something which is
essentially like it's an accident like
nobody saw this come in like like go
figure
it it happened it's terrible but at
least there's a
explanation of sorts like there was some
sort of mechanical failure the panel of
the solar panels whatever on the outside
like it created a chain reaction and bam
it exploded
there's i guess there is an explanation
for this too because you can watch the
timeline if you go back far enough
and see how it foments a lot of unrest
and stuff like that
uh not good which is the mild
understatement of the year
truly um but uh that's why we come here
kids this is our safe space
where you talk about the battles uh
someone could control
and stuff like that for example as we
tear into one division this week
we're all like what's gonna happen
what's it mean somebody out there
already knows and they've seen the
ending so
there's i like i like dealing in terrors
that are modified by
you know running time half hour
eight episodes that kind of thing yeah
i've heard a fake world right now
yeah i mean it's i i prefer not to sweat
those things if i don't have to um and
luckily
native deodorant keeps me from sweating
i if to honor a segway that smooth
ladies and gentlemen
i shouldn't even call attention to it
but it was so stellar
it needs a celebration of its own man it
was
a a sweat-free segue provided by
mr mark bernardin our hosts uh we're the
host this week our sponsor this week on
fatman beyond the good people
uh who are paying our bills and letting
this all happen uh are
the good folks at native kids we've
spoke about them before
i literally just took a shower before we
did this show
native native all over my body if you
could smell me right now
you smell native mark as well probably
i do do you smell like candy canes yes
and if people smell us at the same
like no my internet's unstable that joke
was so hot my internet
went fuzzy
yeah uh you guys all know what native is
ladies and gentlemen
uh native deodorant is formulated
without aluminum parabens or talc
man it's also vegan and never tested uh
on animals or anything like that
uh this is the not only do they make
this kind of
stuff where you know you go under your
pits they make body
lotion they make body wash man tell them
what they make mark
man they make shampoos they make
deodorants they make
everything to make you smell a little
bit better and they got over 10
different scents
including classics and rotating
seasonals um classic scents include coco
coconut and vanilla their most popular
lavender and rose cucumber and mint and
citrus and herbal musk
candy cane was a seasonal one and so i
still smell like christmas
that's right you could smell like
christmas for a while ladies and
gentlemen
well into the new year and stuff me and
mark aren't going to give up on
christmas that's the best part of the
year for heaven's sakes and smelling
like candy canes
one of your new year's resolutions was
to cut down on your plastic consumption
because you're preparing for the
environment
native now offers a line of plastic free
deodorants in the most popular scents
what do you mean plastic free like they
don't put them in plastic containers
apparently not apparently they are
plastic free
that's the option maybe they just give
you a handful of deodorant
yeah like put out your hands there you
go walk away
that means they got to make like a
deodorant thing that's made of like wood
uh maybe your recyclable materials i'm
sure
look at that man they're vegan they
won't test on animals they're thinking
about the environment
these native folks man they all they
just want to wash you
that's it they just smell good they're
on your side they ain't against you
they're for you all they want from you
and all they need from you
you know free shipping on every order in
the u.s and native offers
30 day free returns and exchanges in the
u.s
so if you make the switch to native
today by going to nativedeo.com
batman or use the promo code patman at
checkout you get 20
off your first order 20 2
0. you know you know what 20 is
if they threw in another 80 it's free
so 20 is substantial kids
for the weight of three yes and you're
getting something that's going to
improve your life for heaven's sakes man
it improves mine
i smell i smell good right now somebody
asked me like what's going on with your
sleeves i put on fake sleeves
these are a pair of socks that i cut
open and put on my arms because i hate
my
fish belly white arms and stuff so
that has nothing to do with native but i
thought that was some mutai [ __ ]
like you were you were going into the
stick fighting ring and you're like i
gotta cover some [ __ ]
oh man this is me dressing like ellen
aim from streets of fire i'm getting
ready to sing on stage and [ __ ]
now for you tonight native deodorant
ladies and gentlemen the good folks at
native
are proud sponsors of fat man beyond do
me a favor as you're sitting here
watching this show
go over to nativediodeo.com
uh slash fat man uh and get yourself uh
some native because they're gonna give
you 20
off with you if you use the promo code
fat man at check out
nativedeo.com stop
[ __ ] stanking native
that's their that's our tagline for them
we're working through
yeah i've got something better than that
um less stinking
there you go [ __ ] that's a thinking
man's tagline uh we thanked good folks
at native uh deodorant
for being involved with this haphazard
show of ours um we'll be mentioning them
throughout the evening every time i get
a hint of candy cane
i'll be i'll be thinking of and
mentioning the good folks at native
um i know we're going to talk about uh
wanda vision in a bit but uh should we
bring up our guests and
go through all the stuff we've been
talking about i think we should
i think uh this gentleman has been very
patient waiting in the wings
as we uh blow our deodorant sponsors
nativedeo.com
dot com um let's be here man let's
let's bring him in uh tell us how we got
here mark
we've got uh our guest a fellow named
skylar aston
um who's on a television show called uh
zoe's extraordinary
playlist i keep wanting to say it's
infinite playlist just because i
remember
nick and norah's infinite playlist but
it's not that um
but skyler reached out of the blue and
he was like hey man listen
i'm a fan of the podcast my brother
turned me on to it
um would it be cool if i just swung by
and just shot the [ __ ] with you guys and
i said
yeah man yes you yes yes you can do that
for two reasons a he seemed cool and it
was a good approach
and i always respect that and i am i'm
here for any person who gets to work
with jane levy
who was on castle rock who i got to know
a little bit at uh
at san diego comic-con and i don't think
we were on set together
ever um but she was very very lovely and
i figure if she thinks a person is good
enough to be on a tv show with
then that person is good enough to be a
guest star in our show specious logic
ball accepted ladies and gentlemen
welcome to fat man beyond skylar aston
skylar
how are you i just wanted to do an
entrance like you did
i'm well then what was kyler aston
ladies and gentlemen
why is getting out of here right now
exactly
yeah father where are you are you in los
angeles or new york
i'm actually in rainy vancouver i am on
day 12
of 14 of government quarantine round two
because we are back filming on monday so
we got to go home for christmas and now
i'm back here so explain to the folks at
home
uh who haven't had to encounter this or
you you're on a tv show so in order to
go up there and shoot your tv show
normally pre-pandemic you could fly up
[ __ ] night before show up seven in
the morning go to work
now you can't do that at all no now you
have to have a full
14 days and you got to have tests um
negative tests before you fly and then
we've actually had
uh some nurses come here i've been
tested three times in quarantine they
are
incredibly careful um not only like the
production that i'm on but just straight
up canada they are
rule followers they're like w.h.o says
seven to ten days
not our rules we'll stay well we're
gonna go with our instincts at 14. so
they're being super careful and keeping
their numbers down and so have you been
in that
space that you're in right now for that
amount of time how long you been there
so far
you're looking at it yeah this is day 12
of 14. uh i've been there
i've been here a few times and there
more
um but yeah this is it i was actually
like facetiming with my girlfriend
and i was face i was pacing vigorously
last night and she's like
i'm getting nauseous watching you can
you stay still and like you don't
understand
what i deal with like i cannot go
outside it's
bizarre that's strange so what do you do
for eats
uh i go grocery shopping and i'm able to
accept doordash and you know those kind
of delivery services so i've been doing
a lot of that
this this time around but yeah i've been
like kind of cooking but then that means
you have to
always be cleaning i've been writing
music you know watching stuff keeping
busy doing a lot of press for the show
because the show just came out
do they and this is so weird to ask but
did they pay
actors or for that time that you're
sitting there in the quarantine
that's a great question kevin and uh the
answer is
[ __ ] no actually really yeah
i think that there's some cast members
on our show that are looking into that
um because you know people always assume
that like they're putting me up here and
that i get per diem but
when you're a series regular on a show
and of course not complaining such
privileged work and of course i get a
series regular paycheck but like that
you know you have to factor in your
expenses like that i have to find a
rental apartment in vancouver
a rental car you know food for you know
you know money for food so
you know it's kind of on you but again i
can't complain now
uh being that you're shooting a show in
vancouver
does it heighten your awareness of all
the other shows in vancouver that are
shot where you're like
i've been there i've shot there i've
been oh yeah yeah nothing is europe
anymore nothing is the future
anymore i'm like that's the marina that
is that one
uh gothic building they just built up a
couple stuff with vfx but yeah
and and what's weird is that um last
year i was doing reshoots on a disney
plus
film that i did and there's this place
perhaps you've actually shot there uh
called riverview
uh it's like a mental institution and it
is like
for real haunted in every single way and
so
that's when you hear the stories about
like yeah you know a super girl a girl
disappeared
like when you know when they were
shooting you know they were shooting the
flash and like you should have seen what
happened man
extras just started turning into zombies
but no it was weird it was like don't go
in this room it will lock behind you and
we can't explain why
we've been trying to undo that for years
it was a freaky place but
it looked amazing that's the thing about
vancouver it it doesn't have such an
identity but it keeps it open to really
be malleable for other places
like this could be new york yeah you
know
he was in miami i thought his his you
know drug cartel business was kicking
off and he was in miami
which by the way unrelated it is but no
vancouver for me for now
what is that in the same building we're
quarantining
say it again are there other actors in
the same building who are quarantining
like is it some giant actor prison where
you're like slipping notes under doors
and
honestly that'd be great i wouldn't mind
that um the show creator is going to
move
here after quarantine and we'll actually
be able to hang out um but we're all
actually this year in the same area and
it's pretty walkable
it's a really great spot called yale
town and um just like all the
restaurants
and when you could go places it's it's
the place to go you know please sit down
that's good yeah there's uh what is it
nestor's markets right there
and that's the thing is like this you
know it always be oh it's near the bars
it's near the workout facilities now
it's like it's near the
only two places you could go grocery
store
no other store you know so true
is this season one or two this is the
second um
we uh we shot last you know last year
and it was really well received has a
great cast mary steenburgen jane levy
peter gallagher myself
some really great people and uh it's a
musical so it's like about this girl
it's kind of like a super power show
with musicals
um because this girl has this unique
power due to this crazy phenomenon where
she can hear people's thoughts through
song
so how she navigates that and it can be
a cornball concept but they really
ground it with this great family story
and this love interest storyline and
this year now it's really evolving and
it's it says a lot about like the human
condition and consciousness versus
subconsciousness
but there's also this great reward of
like musical numbers
um are they incorporated since we're in
covent do they incorporate covet or in
your world
of the show that's not a factor i think
in a world where such a power could
exist we're just basically froze 2019
for a minute and
and and i also believe that like i i
kind of like shows that do it when they
have to but i think
in order for this show to stand the test
of time it would immediately date us
and if zoe's getting up at work and
someone's wiping down a surface behind
her i think it'll just be distracting
however i don't want to give away
spoilers for those people who haven't
seen the first season but there's a
little bit of something that she has to
get through and kind of carry on and
soldier on and
find her way back to the workplace for
the first time in person for a while so
you can't help but like think of those
parallels and our show has kind of
always been
meta i think in the right ways and this
is no exception
and where can they watch it is nbc it's
nbc you could catch up on
um you know they did this weird thing
because now they're promoting peacock
but you can you can see the second
season the stuff that's recently aired
on hulu
but if you want to go back to season one
you got to go to peacock but there's a
free version of peacock so you could
actually you know change it there
very true you're gonna get to be in like
rooms with people
and like shake their hands and hug them
and stuff yeah i've
kissed a person multiple times it was
it was out of control i know it it
wasn't subtle either
um but it was it was like a culture
shock for both of us we've done that
before
jane so your favorite i've kissed your
favorite
and i like it um and uh and no this year
was bizarre though because we got tested
every
single day and even the first take it
was like
you know should we and then she's like
you could go for it for real but it was
um
it's just bizarre even doing intimate
scenes and being in a small apartment
with a crew it's like what's happening
here
that is crazy like think about like how
like if it was always it's always a
weird thing in the world of acting where
it's like and then we kiss
because you know kissing is such a
weirdly intimate act and whatnot and
suddenly you're like oh let's just
[ __ ] kiss
now it's like i
i like i don't even know if i [ __ ]
trust you you know what i'm saying like
it's like i would sooner [ __ ] you
at least like you know like the 2021
wrap it up is wear a mask not a condom
it's like
hey i might have a kid but at least i'm
not going to die
yeah exactly i don't want to be burdened
with life not death exactly now can you
and you can't even i mean i guess you
could but like you don't want to you
can't really object like
if you were a performer right now he's
like i don't look i'm [ __ ]
i don't even want to risk it and stuff
but they're like it's for the story
like you can't like you gotta have to go
go with it right like if anyone's a
germaphobe right now they gotta get over
that [ __ ] apparently
i've heard of some stories about some
people on other shows that are like
not breaking their series regular
contract because they have a certain
agoraphobia
you know and they've always been kind of
weird about sanitizing and stuff but now
in this world they're like
or new mothers that are just like i'm so
sorry i'm in australia with my family
like i'm not gonna go to atlanta
where it's worse and like at this stage
in my career i think you can replace me
and it's a weird choice that people have
to make but i think if you sign on to
something
you have to trust the process and i mean
it's been like a
adjustment you know to the new normal
there is literal there are literally
scientists in lab coats and red vests
that
hover over like this separate agency um
around our set and uh it's it's a little
bizarre like we have this beautiful
colorful wonderful world of zoe's
extraordinary playlist and if you bump
the camera a little bit
you will see uh what looks like a
stranger things set or something like
that like
there's people with the gloves and just
full-on hazmat suits
it's so crazy professionals so i'm sure
like
i'm sure they're happy to be working but
beneath it all they must be like
you're [ __ ] we're in the middle of
pandemic and you're making pretend
yeah by the way there's something to be
said about that
and like people get such a bad rap for
that but the thing is like
this this film industry does uh
contribute a ton to bc's economy
and you know on another level you know
people when they're bitching about not
having shows to watch it's like well
we're giving you the shows because the
thing is like if we
keep stopping you're not gonna have a
shows for another as you know
like with editing another two years so
we're we are taking that calculated risk
and
knock on wood in seven episodes no one's
popped and we we've been going i mean
we're airing already it's like happening
[ __ ] hey how what is the lag time
between
the shoot and an airing of an episode
right now um well
we started shooting in august and now
we've had two
episodes air but we stopped at seven so
it's about to catch up to us
and actually uh nbc is this was always a
part of the deal
we're going off for like six weeks and
it'll give post time to catch up and
nbc which has a tetris board right now
you know of scheduling and they got to
figure out
their few shows and how to slot it in so
you know we'll probably uh
take a little bit of a mid-season break
are your songs
new compositions or needle drop their
needle drops and cover songs the whole
thing is she's getting an mri in the
pilot and there's an earthquake in san
francisco
so this guy who's like i got everything
i got literally spotify itunes i got it
it's all in the machine so it all
downloads into her brain
so everything from i've done opera on
the show rock and roll
um you know uh i just did a jet song
always to men recently so it's really
fun it's like um
it's it's interesting too because that
could feel like jukebox musically but
like
um fitting these literal lyrics into a
narrative has been like a challenge and
a reward because
it specifies you know what we're talking
about in the songs we can pick from
and it works kind of well told me man
i'm [ __ ] in that was like
you've done a better job at selling the
show than nbc did i'm like
that's really cool it's pretty wild yeah
and the thing is that like
um and i won't keep like
self-congratulating but
i will say that like a lot of people
when they saw the 30-second promo it
looks a little fun and bubble gummy and
light-hearted and comedy
and then like they get [ __ ] up from
this like family drama storyline they're
like yo i was
super emotional so we do we are hitting
some different you know notes on it
okay um talk a little bit i mean
i don't want to sound like a journalist
because this would be a question i would
ask as a journalist
so tell me how growing up
you reconciled the theater nerd plus
the ghee like those things were they
were they dual tracks for you did you
discover one later earlier
it was kind of a flip for me because
like um and now i've incorporated it and
leveled off and balanced it out
but like when i was growing up i was you
know three uh two brothers
pure boy playing sports uh you know see
playing action figures i had you know
huge into wrestling actually growing up
wwf
um and and would always go see um like
big blockbuster movies with my
my siblings but then again i would also
um since i grew up in the tri-state area
like once
every year twice a year i get to go to
broadway and i was such a big fan
and um i i've been playing piano since i
was five as a hobby
but then i kind of started incorporating
singing
and uh when i kind of realized i wasn't
gonna
advance much in the basketball world i
i i tried like just a one-time thing to
to
audition for a community theater
production of god spell and
uh ended up getting the lead role and
then ended up like kind of doing a full
180
and uh and and got super immersed into
theater and then like went to a theater
camp
talk about geeky i mean like i was doing
les mis at 15 with braces and
and and just got totally bitten by the
bug and then i was on broadway at sis 17
um and then started doing tv and film
and now everything's kind of leveled out
where
like i did this um this film secret
society of second born royals where i
got to do some stunt work
and i realized between dance and
learning choreography and fight
choreography and even the training i've
done with boxing and muay thai
like that's something that i really
enjoy both as i've been doing and um
so yeah i feel like um i embrace every
different side of me and every different
level of geek that i have
how can i man the uh would you were you
in
spring awakening yeah original cast
well [ __ ] man that was huge yeah what's
uh what year was that
that was 2007 but i did the first
like um they do these workshops in new
york it takes forever to get a show to
broadway and so i did the first workshop
in 2005
and then uh six we went off broadway
extended
transfer to broadway 2007 won all these
tonys and
it just went on from there uh one grammy
a grammy award for soundtrack
but it's a it's a fascinating thing
because i've had like other successes
and more commercial i guess successes
but that to me will always be the one
because
is that is broadway success
like translate to tv and movies or like
did it happen instantly when spring
awakening took off were people like hey
come [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
i think like we got to like audition for
some cool mini series
in new york you know and i got this i
got my first film ever
from from the interest of uh spring
awakening but i still like to audition
for
this film called hamlet 2 it's my first
movie ever
and uh i did it on like uh uh
leave of absence from from spring
awakening but other than that i i cut my
teeth doing pilots that never got picked
up and
so many generals that you know i would
say oh i was in
so tell me about this spring awakening
what network was it on and i'm like oh
no it's
not that kind of a show it was a so this
was before social media could really
like
take things like hamilton and make it
translate um
so no in a way i was totally starting
over when i came out to la
it's wild man i imagine like spring
awakening
would be like hey you were on the wire
weren't you
that was cool um so hey do you want to
read for this role i was like no i was i
was on the
best show on tv for a while that's great
but we're looking for something
oh my first pilot that i got was this
like cbs sitcom with
adam corolla and jimmy kimmel and i got
that from the pre-re
phase where you have to read with the
casting director with no camera even
because
they need to screen you to even know if
it's worth recording you
so i mean like 10 callbacks later i'm
like
my show won eight tonys but the thing is
like another thing that theater kind of
teaches you is
really it's it's to try to be egoless
because while you're on the top of your
game
the paycheck isn't that wonderful um
it's such hard work it's such a grind
and uh you know you just don't have
those kind of luxuries they don't feed
you you got to bring your own food if
you're late and get docked
i mean there's like some old school
theater rules so if anything
like that kind of prepared me more work
ethic wise for everything else you know
having some craft services like get out
of here
um all right the chat room is wanting
they're getting wanda anxious okay you
watched uh
wanda vision as well i did yeah mark you
watched wanda division we're all
prepared to dive into wand division
we are indeed uh let's give the kids
what they want uh this weekend
uh ladies and gentlemen disney plus
debuted wanda vision
uh their first you know big show since
the mandalorian as far as i'm concerned
right did i miss anything i think it
that was the
first marvel tv show to premiere on the
disney place
and the first marvel anything that we've
had in over a [ __ ] year
like last thing we had was spider-man
far from home if i remember correctly
then all of 2020 was you know a horrible
abyss of no marble
so sitting down and watching that logo
come up and then seeing that they
incorporated footage from end game into
the logo
you just bathed with this warmth of oh
we're back
like everyone's been craving some
[ __ ] normalcy
that logo alone was worth the price of
admission because it gave you a sense of
like all right maybe things will get
back to
normal one day before the showing began
i was right there uh with it the uh
show itself uh is wonderful it's weird
i mean if you've seen the spots you've
pretty much seen
like the first two episodes there was a
lot of the black and white stuff and
whatnot
and they're set they're will world
building they're setting it up
uh in an interesting way hats off or
mimicking of course
uh what a lot of people refer to as the
nick at night
like look you know in terms of the first
episode was uh what would you say kind
of donna reedish to some degree
exactly but which was definitely the
second one they even flat out have the
like opening animation which was dope
but like you know watching them do
these incredibly loyal homages
like that's entertaining in and of
itself particularly because it's like
hey those two cats are movie stars man
like so that's a great gimmick right
then and there and you could probably
get away with that
if it was just the show but we all know
that the show is
something more that on the surface it's
bright and poppy and underneath
there's a sadness you know this seems
like wanda is broken we all know that
vision
is dead um and we didn't even come back
through the portals and end games so
he's just
[ __ ] dead dead dead and yet here he
is standing beside her and whatnot so
clearly she's at a break
with reality and she's creating uh her
own reality a pocket universe
perhaps uh we don't know what it is they
haven't [ __ ] told us yet
but pocket universe seems to be you know
um
plausible explanation um which means we
could see
rob liefeld's captain america at any
moment
tiny feet and large pectoral muscles
remember that pocket universe
so many badges
your hero's reborn that was a pocket
universe um
a lot of folks have speculated on
twitter over the last 48 hours
um about the connection of this or the
inspiration it may
have derived from the classic storyline
house of them which for you know
for those who aren't well schooled in
this the highlight the biggest moment
from house of them is juan and maxim off
and a close-up says
three simple words that changed the
marvel universe for a long like [ __ ]
time and it was no more mutant she got
rid of
she's the most powerful mutant in the
world she got rid of all the [ __ ]
mutants in the marvel
universe and no more were gonna happen
and stuff like that so
obviously they can't do that here there
are no mutants in the current
marvel cinematic universe although we
know there will be
because they got you know they bought
the fox library so mutants are on their
way and some people are speculating
that it begins with juan division
maybe she's creating alternate realities
where we're going to pull mutants in
from or something like that
but a lot of folks pointed to that one
moment
in episode two where she sees the
beekeeper
and come out of the ground like we've
seen in the trailer a zillion times
and then they go in close on her and she
just said like no
and all of a sudden everything rewound
and took them back to the moment before
they went inside
outside and suddenly everything changed
to call her so they're giving you
the impression with that that like if
she doesn't like something
she can completely [ __ ] change it she
can
rewind she could reset she could write a
happy ending for herself and that's kind
of what it seems like she's
all about at this moment in time writing
happy endings for herself
which to me just like it screams that
it's gonna be [ __ ] heartbreaking
that's what i'm [ __ ] there for
i'm happy they're doing the nick and
knight stuff it's very clever
but i'm there to watch wanda break down
because wanda maximoff has had a hard
[ __ ] life and they picked the right
character
to kind of head in this direction with i
don't know if they're turning her into a
big bad
you know for multiverse of madness if
it's going to be strange versus her
or if it's going to be strange and wanda
trying to fix what she's broken in one
division
but it seems like in phase four man
they're they're building
lizzie olsen up to be [ __ ] huge like
wanda's
taking the [ __ ] stage in a big bad
way and when you look at all their
previous work on the marvel universe
because
after the show you know i went to
youtube and did one of those dives where
you're like
every wanda scene ever you know and
people put those together
she's only been in these marvel movies
for a total of 20 minutes
if you compile all her [ __ ] so we're
seeing
more of wanda and vision in one division
than we've ever seen in
any of the previous incarnations in the
marvel cinematic universe for that it's
exciting
i'm impatient as [ __ ] though i want to
see i want the pain
i want the sorrow i want the tragedy i
want the real world to encroach
a lot faster than it's encroaching i
love the two moments the one in episode
one
with the neighbors uh where um you know
the wife is
jeber joe rob is like stop it stop it
stop it that [ __ ] was like
lynchian david lynchian i liked her
looking at the radio
and episode two and hearing like wanda
wandy can you read us
and the beekeeper coming out of the
ground with the sword [ __ ] uh you
know
outfit on i i want more of that and i'm
sure we're gonna get that
so i'm i'm just patiently doing this
enjoying the [ __ ] out of it
my my wife who doesn't like any of this
[ __ ] literally stayed up with me until
one in the morning or 12 you know when
it when it they put it up on
on disney plus out here and like watch
both episodes with me and
you know did that thing that like i love
more than watching the movies is
explaining to people
what is happening in the movies because
i know it's so well
so like every time she was like what's
going on i could pause and be like well
this is what happened years ago you know
and i could do the deep dive
and she was engaged enough with the
program to tolerate me normally she's
like i don't care just
it's too confusing so after i walked her
through it she was like all right press
play and she was [ __ ]
in man and i think that has everything
to do with the performances
elizabeth olsen paul bettany absolutely
crushing it they got their characters
down to a science yes but they get to do
a lot more
in this than they've ever done in the
movies as
vision and the scarlet witch um for a
guy that collected the comic book
miniseries back in 1985 when i was a kid
or whatever it came out
um it was thrilling to watch the
these two characters take center to
stage and to take center stage with what
i
smell it's a very [ __ ] tragic story
gentlemen take over skyler what do you
think you go
and then i i will do the thing i do oh
well um all right
well i think that uh you know it's an
interesting way of like letting
um the audience into the world that's
kind of the old classic way of doing it
in the 50s it was like this soft-serve
way
of of presenting in almost a diorama way
characters and in a way it kind of
reintroduced paul bettany and lizzie
olsen and it's it's kind of like uh
if you have the patience it's like a
star-making performance because like you
could totally see in another world lizzy
olsen
playing lucy or you know what i mean
paul bettany doing a dick van dyke thing
and you got to see homages to that
um i thought for sure when i initially
heard that
that they were releasing the first two
episodes i told my brother
i was like so that's what so i will bet
you
that the whole first episode is black
and white and at the very end you get
some color and then we're gonna really
start to get going in episode two
i didn't realize that we were gonna get
like three and a half easter eggs over
the course of two episodes so
um i have i do however have blind faith
in the
marvel universe and um you know
also i i that that opening that cold
open
or just that's the credits was like a
warm blanket for me
um so and also the first time seeing it
on television i think
i don't know that i've seen that on tv
tv like other than watching you know
end game on on blu-ray so uh i
i thought that was thrilling um i'm very
in i love the catherine han character
uh i think i i i think there's just a
lot of setup and and i and there's not
much to really weigh in on because
uh not much has happened however i i
couldn't help but think that while they
were satirizing the 1950s version of a
sitcom
that laugh track was like i felt a level
of darkness in it
because the jokes themselves weren't
really that funny
so you know it almost feels like um
antagonistic
like the the laugh track is laughing at
the leads
um so while they're putting on a brave
face you could feel that kind of tension
there
so i i like the subtle hint of that and
i like the style of it
um i like any any time someone could do
something in an unusual way and with
style and that's definitely what they're
going for here
i think that the reveal of the color
world was better than any wizard of oz
could ever do it
i almost wish i saw that on the big
screen other than that it worked very
well in the aspect ratio where it was
presented and i'm really interested to
see where it goes from here
let's talk about katherine hahn real
quick uh she's playing a character
called the
agnes right now but everyone online
seems to think
uh because she's wearing a very similar
broach
to a character called ag of the harkness
from marvel that she is this witch
character
uh just going by a shortened or a
different name there's been some
speculation about in the credits they
did uh you know
uh at the end of the show the first
episode there
somebody you know they pulled back and
they so showed somebody from sword
which could be darcy um kat denning's
character
watching the show with credits one of
the credits
was the name of a character from
spider-man one of the kids in the
spider-man movies
um that seemed like a deep divey kind of
uh
like let's try to piece this together i
don't know that that was
necessarily intentional but you never
know with marvel they could be doing
that there's a
little easter eggs like the bottle of uh
wine the house of m my my song do
whatever it was like a house of m
reference and i think there's like a
date
on the bottle as well that was kind of a
reference um
monica rambo uh has shown up uh for
those who are like who's that
she was the daughter of captain marvel's
uh best friend what was her name i
forget but we know her daughter's name
is demonic
she's the one that like she gave the
jacket to when she was good got marvel
came took the jacket back so give that
[ __ ] jacket kid
she's the kid that picked out the color
design on captain marvel suit as she was
sitting there putting the suit together
so that took place in the 90s
this takes place in present day so
monica rambo all grown up
from from the comics uh back in the day
monica rambo also goes on to become a
captain marvel one day if i remember
correctly
so not sure what's going on with the
character how she's in play here other
than it sounds like she may be based on
the trailers more than anything else
she may be working for sword um spoilers
and in the spots that they've been
showing where
clearly somebody gets jettisoned out of
wanda's reality
um it looks like monica rambo so
clearly she must work for sword or
somebody on the side of the good people
trying to
get in and pull um wanda out
now on the listing for the show on
disney plus
like you know they is comedy or blah
blah blah but one of the
descriptions was mystery and i thought
that was rather appropriate because
that's kind of what they're building
here
uh but then i also realized that i'm
[ __ ] no good with mysteries like
because i just want to know what
happened
so like i almost wish they would start
at the end and then just
fill us in you know later on i just want
to know what the [ __ ] happening and
what's going wrong
but everybody of course feels that way
as well i'm here for it
week after week but i would much prefer
if they just did a [ __ ] dump but at
the same time
look what it does every week it's going
to create a conversation with people and
stuff it's so strange
to live in this moment in time where
you're like oh wow how cool they're
stretching the story out
and making me come back for it week
after week as if this is a [ __ ] new
concept like
you raised it like the idea of you know
oh you can't watch this every week you
got or you can't watch it every day or
whatever you want you only get it like
once a week
and it's so weird that we've gone so far
flung of that where it's like
i can watch whatever i want when i want
i don't need a video store i can just
[ __ ] pull it down on my laptop
and now we're kind of they're bringing
us back to this world where they're like
no no we're just gonna give you a piece
at a time man if you're really good
we'll give you two at a time
um it's strange because like at some
moment
i'm like wow this is revolutionary i'm
like it's not revolutionary they're just
doing the same old [ __ ]
that we used to do back in the day uh
mark do i detect a little
a little some spice for this proper cash
is
[Music]
two things are true at the same time the
first
i really enjoyed watching these two
episodes like i kind of had a good time
with it and elizabeth olsen is doing
like
awesome work and paul bettany is a lot
funnier than i remember him being
um but i should also remember that he's
funny like you know
the first time i saw him was in a
knight's tale where he's playing him
just out and out comedic character like
he's got all of those chaps
but also if this wasn't a marvel show
i would not watch more than that first
episode like
the the faith that i have the investment
that i now have in the marvel cinematic
universe
is the reason why i'm coming back not
because either those episodes
earned my return you know like like
we've gotten very
fresh this i think with time despite the
fact that 10 doesn't exist anymore
um because there's so much to watch
because there's so many options because
they're so
the the the smorgasbord just seems to go
on forever
and so if i'm gonna give a half an hour
to anything like all right
earn it earn it in my half an hour like
you get one of these
maybe two if you're lucky um and the
second is simply on charm
um but you get one and if i had to judge
this
independent of it being scarlet witch
and vision
i don't know if i would come back for a
second episode because to your point
kind of nothing happens like there's
little kind of
prison of interesting and a little tiny
bit of sinister
but like you've got to tell me what the
show is like
at the end of the the pilot for lost
like there's a giant [ __ ] polar bear
and a smoke monster and somebody says
guys where are we and they're like yeah
where the [ __ ]
are we because this is insane a plane
crashed like
and like stuff happened and i don't
understand any of it
i i just have to pause you just so just
to read you
some of the feedback mark yes please
here we go ready just just a sampling i
agree with the guy who's talking
please preach preach preach spit games
son uh exactly built in loyalty
this uh it agreed with mark
uh it's true i'm staying because i love
the big picture not because the episodes
were that good
you you may have nailed it mark for a
lot of people um
yeah i co-signed that if it wasn't
marvel and if it wasn't the you know
vision and the scarlet witch if i didn't
know or suspect based on the trailers
of what its connection is to everything
to something i already love
one episode probably would have been
like oh that's clever and then i'm
moving on and stuff but
you're right because it's marvel i'm
like no no something's gonna happen i'll
wait
and i also can't fault them for knowing
that that i'm
that person right like they know who we
are
and they know we're gonna stick around
and they know how much we bring to it so
they know we
know that scarlet witch is is grieving
desperately the loss
of her great love and so we know you me
skyler everybody watching knows that
this is her
sort of fantastical imagination he's
creating all this stuff
we're bringing so much to the table and
all they're doing is giving us a nice
black and white version of that table
and we're like i can't wait till the
thing i think is going to happen happens
or i can't wait till they tell me the
thing that i think is going to happen
isn't what's happening but they'll tell
me something else and that'll be cool
like
we are in participant in this drama
marty
marty
morton in the chats is summing you up by
saying i've invested 28 years in marvel
i don't need the dragon the show was
okay
like you you kind of did hit the nail on
the head which is like my
what keeps me in my seat was my
investment
like of in the universe what made the
show vastly entertaining for me in the
first two
episodes other than just watching the
show and seeing it come to life
i think it's very bold i i like where
it's going but yes i'd like it to
hurry up and stuff but it was made more
enjoyable for me by somebody who was
absolutely lost in the room and i could
be like oh
well i can tell you everything about
this [ __ ] and if i didn't have that
you know it might have i might have like
noticed
like you did i might have been like huh
huh
yeah and it's right like skyler turned
me around on something because i
i was also and he completely recognized
what they were doing he's like oh yeah
that's dick van dyke and that's
bewitched and that's i love lucy
but it's not as funny as any of them are
you know and the question is is that not
funny on purpose
or is that not funny just we couldn't
figure out a way to be as funny
as classic sitcoms which is hard because
they're great
and it was skyler mentioning that the
laugh track has become this kind of
sinister this minor chord in the in the
kind of orchestration of the show that's
adding this level of dread to it
because it's laughing at things that
aren't funny you know
and i do just kind of wonder if there
was another way to play that
where the jokes worked and the laugh
crack drops out for the things that are
funny
but it starts to laugh at the things
that aren't funny and like
just to to better succeed at the
facility that this is actually a classic
sitcom
instead of just this weird meta kind of
50s cosplay with these characters even
though i appreciate the lengths to which
they've gone
to replicate that feel and that mood and
that
you know the weird sadness of everything
and the weird like
you know big low mood of everybody walks
in that door
everybody's more chipper than they have
any right to be chipper about
um but but but i do like i sense
that thing that skyler was getting at
but i also kind of just
i wanted it to be the thing that it was
um
and i kind of wanted not to feel as if
it was a shortcoming
but rather an on-purpose decision that
they made
um but like all of this to say they know
exactly who i am
and they know that i'm going to watch
all of it and so i can't blame them for
knowing that
like to pretend that they don't know
that would be like
duh why why should they pretend that
they don't know that
so i'm in but only because it's marvel
in a way not because the show is earning
it but because the marvel cinematic
universe has earned it already you know
this is
this is the like we're skating because
we already won the trophy
and so hey it's all good we don't have
to skate that hard we have to skate that
fast it's
it's the it's the pro ball like there's
nobody keeping score
here like we're just here to do a
victory lap guys and we're
hanging out in hawaii for two weeks and
gotta get a bunch of lays on and
drink a lot of my ties and maybe throw a
ball or two
is that a for those of us that don't
follow sports but do follow hockey would
that be the equivalent of say the
all-star game
indeed that is the you did good all year
it's even different because it's after
the super bowl so truly no one cares
it's not even in the middle of it
it literally is done like they're on
full vacation trying not to get hurt for
the following year
oh i thought you were making an analogy
for like marvel where you're like
this is after the super bowl like
endgame was a super bowl [ __ ] well in
a way also that is the truth
which by the way makes the metaphor of
uh the pro bowl
all the more you know accurate even
sweeter smeasel
in our comment section uh in the chat on
uh youtube says i get what mark is
saying but i think starting the audience
within the fantasy
was enough to have me invested just
mimicking the classic sitcom in 2020
is enough to give an impression of
what's coming
um yeah i look i agree and again i love
to conceit
uh i was happy when they got out of
black and white and that's so weird
because i made clerks
but like i was very happy when we got to
the 70s in color because that
maybe it's because like all the footage
i've seen where [ __ ] starts going wrong
is in color so i was like the faster we
get out of the black and white era the
closer we'll get to the plot you know
into the outside
world tim gildersleeve in chat said i
pointed
out the line uh where she said my
husband and his indestructible head
which
you know was kind of funny considering
that [ __ ] thanos proved her way wrong
uh jc did you watch it you're i know
you're you know the resident
star wars kid but you got some marvel
skin in the game did you watch enough
i did watch it and um i felt
very similar to mark but i was also
struck i mean this was only
like 22 minutes per episode so if you
think back to the first episode of
game of thrones which was like an hour
long
i remember watching that and going what
the [ __ ] am i watching
who are all of these people what are
they doing why are they walking on this
thing called the king's road
and then the last like 10 seconds of the
episode it's like
oh my god that brother and sister are
[ __ ] and they just killed a kid
right so perhaps at the end of episode
three
we'll get that moment in one division
that's
very much like what where you're blown
away by it
um but i think you know i mean
we just haven't seen very much of it
and if it's going to be a slow burn and
they're gonna give us that
end of game of thrones holy cow moment
at the end of episode three
you know i'm in for it i'm excited
i mean i'm not gonna keep watching but
like
yeah mind you without anybody going like
it don't work this is just us going like
it works good give us more
um finding a stranger in the alps in the
chat
said the commercials and the episodes
are referencing wanda's trauma the
beeping stark toaster bomb
that almost killed her and her brother
and the struck her watch
when he experimented on her with the
loki staff
um i you know i honestly i did not pick
that up until
i mean i knew they were like oh one is
stark industries and one is
stroker like the watch like like the uh
baron but then then i was it was until
afterwards i was online i was like oh my
god like those weren't
just kooky little spots they threw in
for marvel fans that's part of the
[ __ ] story for wanda
i think anything going into that
pleasantville tone is innately dark
it is it is a reminder it's the contrast
happy happy happy means like
we're covering we're covering for
something that wanda's that that
it's gonna override like wanda's ability
i also wonder if they like
um if they did you know if you if they
release this like all ten i don't know
how many episodes it's actually ordered
for but like
let's say eight or ten episodes if they
release it all at once and you got to
digest it in one or two sittings
i wonder if we wouldn't be you know i
wonder if maybe they should have
if something wild happens at the end of
three then maybe that's what they should
have given us three at once or something
like that
just to give all the people who have
come to expect a little bit more action
uh something that to settle their nerves
a little bit um
then again i do maintain my stance
on the fact that they have you know with
the comics they've earned it for longer
amounts of time but even with the film
and now tv adaptations they've earned
you know
me to sit on my ass for an hour and like
it
you know embrace the setup of it all
embassy nerdcore in chat said
the indestructible head was wanda's
first
line meaning before she even figured out
her backstory the wedding date etc
she decided from moment one that vision
in this reality
needed that feature i love when people
deep dive like i would never
[ __ ] put that together like oh my god
like that there's a sadness even to that
line where she's like
i wish he had an indestructible head
that would have [ __ ] changed the game
eric nelson is pointing out uh he says
devil
in quotes equals mephisto thoughts there
was one reference that i think
agnes made at one point something about
the devil
and at that point i said to my wife like
oh my god the devil in marvel comics is
mephisto
and then i went back to watching the
show do you we think
there's like in the animated bewitched
opening
there was a helmet a grim reaper helmet
shadow outline in like what looked like
a case or something like that
do do we feel this is being done to her
by somebody else
you know like personally i don't think
so
you know and and i don't quite think
that that
mcfisto the festival feels very big for
what this seems like it's going to be
you know this seems to be a little bit
more intimate and a little bit more
you know sword which is like the
sentient
weapons observation response division
you know it seems like they're a watch
group more than they are a you know
we're going to go in and start doing
[ __ ] to people group
and also this tension weapon part is
like well shouldn't you be here for
vision and not scarlet witch but okay
whatever sure
but yeah i mean it it feels as if it's
she's doing something and they're afraid
that it's gonna go bad
and so they're they're keeping tabs on
her trying to pull her out of her own
mind before it
does something awful to the real world
um
and that awful thing may or may not lead
directly into doctor strange too
which is does she create a multiverse
that
hadn't existed before does she does she
shatter
the fabric of reality well i mean what
everyone's wondering and or
and or hoping for online is that it's a
variation
on no more mutants where instead she
just says
more mutants that's what populates
the marvel universe i while i loved that
you know i loved no more mutants in
house of m
i i don't you know look i'll take
mutants anyway and get them in this mcu
but i
i don't i hope that's not it i hope it's
not
like she's like she wishes mutants um i
mean the other thing that it could be
is you know there there is a multiverse
and we
kind of know that there is a multiverse
um
and maybe the thing that she does is
rather than shatter everything into a
multiverse is
collapse all the multiverses into one
and so the universe that had mutants
is now this universe the universe that
had vampires
is now this universe the universe that
had a fantastic four
is now this universe and so it's the way
you get
to incorporate all of that other [ __ ]
and make it into the one thing
that we now can move forward on and so
it's less
i'd like some mutants please and more oh
[ __ ] the world that have mutants the
marvel
619 universe is now earth one
you know the universe that had vampires
so we can bring blade in
is now earthborn and all of this [ __ ] is
here together
and some for somehow reason whatever
doctor strange
in that sequel has to find a way to
balance that because the world is
tearing itself apart because there's too
much world in it
maybe i don't know making [ __ ] up as i
go um
yeah no i that sounds viable um i i just
don't know
like is somebody here somebody said what
i thought it might be
um let me find it we just went by um
while you're finding it one of the um
one of the chainsaw
in chat said that the 23 for the
anniversary
there has been 23 mcu films
is that right yeah
um somebody i can't find the message but
their
their breakdown was like sword
sent wanda in to
some place and she got absorbed into it
so that
they're the they're saying this isn't
her creating it
yeah is trapped in a thing hence the
wanda wanda who's doing this to you and
stuff like that
that's my takeaway i i think it feels
jailish
it feels matrixy it feels truman showy
it feels like something's controlling it
whether it's a big bad
or it's sword or it's even both
grappling for her
and i think that could be an interesting
statement on the person who could
control
anything and change reality actually has
no control of this one so within this
little box
literally she could control the
narrative but beyond that she has no
control in fact she's shackled to it for
now
how pissed and or elated will people be
if it just turns out to be
old x-men villain arcade
people like no it should have been
mephisto like well
he you know mutants i guess all right
i'll take arcade
but i uh i do i i like the idea that
i personally want it to be like her
sorrow
is creating all this [ __ ] but i would be
happy if
it was there was a backstory like we
sent her in on a mission and she hasn't
come out
and something's wrong like that'd be
kind of dope
like that'd be dope world building and
it's much i'm hoping it's all for the
sake of storytelling because like you
said there's an area of mystery
also with strange you know and wanda
there's an
there's a huge cerebral element so we
have to stop and stop with the
explosions and think for a second so we
need to like lay things out slowly
and then on top of that it is you know a
marvel property so there needs to be a
big bad villain so i actually think it's
gonna be
a deep emotional superhero
tv show with style i'm in
i'm in also i'm optimistic and deep in
quarantine so i need this guys
don't we all let's talk about those
lucky [ __ ] that got to see three
episodes a lot of people in chat were
saying that
uh episode three according to the the
critics who've seen it thus far
they they ship three episodes because
that's where it really starts to
coalesce
for anybody in the audience like i guess
if you're
way deep into this stuff maybe you get
there sooner than some folks
i have not myself but uh there's
they they're speculating that three
episodes were sent out because by the
third
by the end of the third there's clearly
a like
oh this is what's going on so it sounds
like maybe one more week
and then we get a lot of questions
answered yeah like i that's that's kind
of how i
how i felt about the first two is that
you're you've peeled back just a little
bit of the wrapping paper on the present
enough to see that like oh [ __ ] there's
colors under here that's cool
but i kind of wanted like a full side to
be like
oh now i see what's happening you know
like
and also i kind of wish that if we're
gonna skip decades into sitcoms that we
went a little faster
like get get me to the jeffersons um
that's kind of where i want to be so
move on up
somebody said i don't know if this is
true but they looked at the area code
for west view and it was 732. that's
jersey baby
you ain't [ __ ] kidding son
[Music]
i heard that online i was like what um i
was so
better at jersey holy [ __ ] this is
different bro
let's watch boxing i'm like they could
take as long as they [ __ ] want now
pop back in because somebody asked a
question uh
about your skull in the background they
were like is that a havoc staff
what do you got back there behind you um
let me go grab it
that is a life-size tauntaun skull
that i 3d printed hold on it's huge
um he just casually throws it out there
it's like
a 3d uh life-sized tonton skull that i
3d printed
as you do right i found it past the
first marker because he froze
look at that [ __ ] that is dope man so
what somebody put up
a design online to print up your own
[ __ ]
tonton skull yeah so somebody did like a
kickstarter and they had this and a
rancor
like greedo but i thought like a
life-size tauntaun skull would be cool
to hang on the wall of scum and villainy
back when you know scum and villainy was
open
that what's that
put it in the baby's room oh yeah she'd
like that
it's like you know if you have any sort
of fireplace it belongs right above it
fantastic um all right man so that's
what we got for one division for you
this week
uh mercifully we'll have [ __ ] to talk
about for the next few weeks
it's gonna be all wand division all the
time
um until this is done and then am i
wrong
are they is falcon and winter soldiers
starting shortly after that
um i think in march they had talked
about
falcon and winter soldiers so if we get
and again like skyler said i have no
idea how long the the order is how many
episodes we get of wanda vision
but it very well could bring us to to
talking with soldier and maybe they
dovetail who the hell knows
magic [ __ ] time marvel's got a spot
of balls now right at home
thank god the marvel cinematic universes
come to your living room kids over on
disney plus go check out wand division
if you haven't seen it yet
um don't believe anything we said
think about you think it out for
yourself uh meantime uh you want to
stick around scholar we're gonna talk
about some other [ __ ] we saw
i'm here to hang um i saw uh what did i
watch this i watched three movies in a
row
um because i was after i was done
writing clerks three
um i celebrated by like now i just wanna
watch other people's stuff
and i watched um promising young woman
have you seen that yet
no i've heard it's good though i
actually have a link to it i'm supposed
to watch i hear she's amazing yeah
it's insanely well done carrie carrie
mulligan that's her name
um wonderful uh does a great job he's
got a great cast
well-written um it is stylishly directed
uh really good watch that was on i want
to say amazon or something like that
um then i watched uh
i want to call it i forget what it's
called but
jc can you look up it's a rain wilson
movie
and he falls in a hole essentially
that's the plot and i can't
that's not the title like the whole but
two it's it was like these two kids are
like robbing a house
and then they're running away and he's a
security guard and
he goes to chase him but then he falls
down this like old well shaft and so
he's stuck in the movie and the
one brother is like [ __ ] leave him
there and the other brother's like we
gotta get him
i think it's called don't tell a soul
that's the name of it
the title makes no sense i would have
called it the hole in the woods but
whatever [ __ ]
um totally [ __ ] good watch where at
first i was like all right i know where
this is going and then they kept
twisting and turning it every half hour
it was kind of impressive
and then i watched um a movie with the
girl from get out
allison williams and it would i want to
say it's called horizon line
um is a movie about like her and another
dude
in a plane like a piper cub one of those
me
you know with a propeller plane and the
guy
uh who's i think it was keith david has
a heart attack the pilot
and they're like [ __ ] there's nowhere
to land
and they're like in the middle of the
ocean and nobody knows how to fly the
[ __ ] plane
so i watched the trailer and i'm like
all right [ __ ] like that's
that's like clerksian one set a couple
characters you know i wanted to see how
they pulled this [ __ ] off
and um it was interesting and as much as
like
yeah i guess if you're doing a whole
movie set inside a [ __ ] plane
a small plane like this is how how you
would how you would pull it off
so i i did fall asleep watching it and
that tends to make any movie better
right because it compresses time
and then you wake up and you're like
that was good like my wife watched the
whole thing and she was like
i was bored but i watched a shortened
version of the movie because i'd fallen
asleep
and i was quite entertained um so those
are the things that i watch what'd you
watch this week
um let's see i watched speaking of
clerksian limited locations film i
watched one night in miami
oh yeah regina king's directorial debut
which is based on a play um written by
kemp
powers who also wrote the screenplay and
also co-directed and co-wrote um seoul
which just came out a couple weeks back
on the disney plot um very talented dude
but it's about a a a single night
in 1963 when um
muhammad ali malcolm x fam cook
and um jim brown
are all hanging out um they're all down
there for them cassius clay's fight
against um oh [ __ ] sunny listen
um and so it's it's all about like these
four
sort of titans of culture
just being together in ultimately what
is one hotel room
for an evening and what happens when
these four people collide
and contrast and complement each other
and
and it's it is very much it was a stage
play
and so it's very much built like a stage
play you know
regina finds ways to open it up there's
you know flashbacks to other events
there's you know two or three
other locations added to it but it's it
is just this
really wonderful character study of of
what it's like to have been a
a paragon of your culture
at a time when the culture desperately
needed those paragons
and then what it's like to also just be
human beings in and amongst
you know the world at that time so you
know what
what makes malcolm x laugh you know like
what makes
you know cactus clay be serious you know
how
how do these people who have so much in
common
um differ in their opinions as to
you know ways to to help improve the
culture especially for african americans
at the time
and it's it's just so well thought out
it's so deeply empathetic for all of
these people
um and it's trying its best to be honest
about what may or may not be a fictional
event but
who these men were at this time and and
the pressures that were forcing them
into or away from um the situations they
would eventually find themselves in
the cast is phenomenal the performances
are terrific
and it's it's hard i'm sure you can
speak to it as well as anybody care of
to
squeeze every last bit out of one
location and not make it feel
claustrophobic and not make it feel kind
of
just like wall bound and she finds ways
to move this camera in what is
ultimately a two-room hotel suite
in in ways that that open it up
emotionally and physically um it's it's
it is a marvel to watch and if it feels
like it's well
it should win all the awards um but who
the hell knows what happens in a year
like this
when what do awards mean like what is
the competition like
what is when do we get to have oscars or
or golden globes or any of that stuff
um but ultimately it almost doesn't
matter because it is this wonderful
piece
that uh i think everybody should watch
like and if you need a thing if you have
your amazon primes
and you're looking for a thing to watch
on martin luther king day about black
history
this is as good a thing you could choose
to watch as any
what's a and just virginia king directs
it but she's not in it at all
no not at all like that actor move when
they
after they've worked because she's been
working since she was a [ __ ] kid
right
like 2-7 baby since how old she was
going 2-2-7
and like yeah so she was like a pre-teen
i think when she was
like 14. so here she is like
you know working in this business for
close to if not over 30 years and stuff
she just turned 50. so yeah eating
behind every
different kind of director who's ever
directed her in something
building her own estimation of like well
this is what i would do if i was in
charge and then you get to step up to
the plate
and i always think it's very like um
generous of actors who make that
transition
to not like put themselves in it my
first instinct would be like
[ __ ] you after like not getting picked
forever now i'm directing i'm putting
myself in the [ __ ] thing
but i always think it's really like kind
of cool and classy when it
when an actor doesn't have to appear in
his thing like robert redford made
ordinary people but he ain't in ordinary
people and everyone treated him
seriously
like as a director because that and it's
certainly no slight to people who put
themselves in their own movie clearly i
put myself in my
movies ben affleck puts himself in his
own movies and stuff
um but i i think it shows a great deal
of restraint
for for an actor uh to be like you know
i'm going to let somebody else shine
think about it's baked in we got one
right here it's baked into the
personality is it a schuyler you're like
i want to be
in front of the center yeah i mean look
i've always wanted to direct but
i think if i ever made that transition i
actually would
prefer to not be in it because i just
want to wear one hat i want to be able
to
i think be taken seriously the only way
i would put myself in it is with is if i
saw so much
value from a producerial standpoint
where i
like i i did pitch perfect 2 with
elizabeth banks she directed that movie
she was not the first choice to play her
character in the franchise it was
supposed to be amy poehler and then
availability
and then it came to a point where she
was with the studio being like
i mean i'm on that list and we're going
way below it at this point like i should
probably put myself in there so i think
that's the only way i would do it
if i saw some sort of value however say
that tell that to robert redford
um but uh but no i i think that that's
very noble i'm very excited to see that
that sounds awesome
yeah and i think that it is part of that
you know to your point skyler the the
the producerial map you know like does
kevin costner get
80 million dollars to make dances rules
if he's also not
in it like i'm the star like i'm a
[ __ ] movie star and
the reason why you're letting me direct
it is because i'm the guy who you
have to have in it to be able to make
this movie yeah if rocky had uh
sylvester stallone direct nicholas cage
it would have been a bit different
totally the nicholas cage has anyone
seen the trailer for willy's wonderland
no but i've heard things nick cage
you know essentially what is it one
night at freddy's or whatever like nick
cage
in uh [ __ ] chuck e cheese
fighting all the robots come to life
i'm here for it god bless her how how
the [ __ ] is that not taken the world by
storm
like i know we're all happy about
wandabish but like that sounds like the
most amazing movie ever made
yeah when does that come out i don't
know they just popped up the trailer man
but
we've been on that i will take scopious
amounts of edibles and we will talk
about that
we would show that trailer uh skyler but
every time we show anything we get in
trouble and they throw us off
all right i am sort of here i remember
you know reading an article with
nicholas cage where somebody was like
dude
you could have been the
they offered him the sopranos they
offered him breaking bad they
they've offered him any number of tv
shows and he's always like i'm a movie
actor
like i do movies and to him it doesn't
seem to matter
the level of the movie just as long as
it's a movie movie
and it's like [ __ ] all right if you're
gonna do you know
colorado space and mandy and willie's
wonderland
like i'm kind of here for this late
period
you know nicholas cage is just making
[ __ ]
it's good [ __ ] he's making cool choices
uh in chat
the big b moss said for the second
episode in a row
what is under kev's chin i don't know
what he means by that
i'm trying to look is it my second chin
is that what you mean i
i don't know what would be under my chin
i think it's the
the shadow of the ring light makes your
beard
look very dark oh is that right i think
so
that's kind of what i'm seeing i also
wanted to chime in and say
um our pal uh fat black patrick swayze
and chat
uh had some thoughts on one night in
miami
uh fat black patrick swayze said one
night in miami was like a superhero
meetup movie
without the superheroes that's which i
thought was great
that's an excellent description it is
very much like you know
let's all get together and fight racism
and i'm here for that always
the uh somebody in chat the camp it
passed by i gotta find it but they were
like
i'm white well i like this
i think yes i think i hope so and you
should
yeah i don't think much to do with
whether you'll enjoy the movie or not
but
i think if you like well-made stuff
sounds like it's well made did you see
anything else
mark um i watched the show on netflix
which um it's called no i'll pronounce
it in the
in the if you just read it way lupin
l-u-p-i-n
if you are uh fancy uh it's lupine
because it's french and and lupine
is a is a french literary character
who i suppose the closest analogy would
be in terms of
kind of like style and grace is sherlock
holmes it was like france's response to
sherlock holmes
and that he's a gentleman burglar he's
incredibly smart
super erudite very well healed um who
would just kind of like
travel the world and like do crime but
in like really sweet ways
um a bit like simon templar you know
like he became like
oh i'm gonna do a lot of disguises and
i'm gonna you know kind of help people
but also
rob the rich and give to the poor and
also myself because i like to drive nice
cars and wear nice clothes
um the character has been adapted a
bunch of different times in both live
action and animation
in japan um hayao miyazaki made a lupine
castle of cagliostro film there's a
brand new loop in the third
um cgi animated movie that looks crazy
fun that just dropped like two months
ago
um but this is a character
um played by omar sai who won all kinds
of awards for the untouchables
he was bishop in one of those x-men
movies
um you know one of the less good x-men
movies
but he's a son of a senegalese immigrant
whose father is uh is brained for a
crime he didn't commit
and kills himself in prison and so now
this kid grows up by himself in france
and styles himself after this this
you know notorious literary character
and it's like
almost a week and it's incredibly fun
and so it's just like ocean's 11 meets
thomas crown affair meets
um leverage which was one of my favorite
tv shows
of the last like 10 years like it's just
got such a bounce to it and such
just it's and it's french so like it
looks amazing because they're shooting
in paris and the first thing is a heist
at the louvre and they get to [ __ ]
shoot in the louvre
you know and it's it's not vancouver
there's a giant glass [ __ ] pyramid
and it's the louvre and it's amazing um
but it was it was that kind of just
effervescent little
kind of bouncy drama that i was looking
for
at perspective the time that i was
looking for it which was on the heels of
a
notorious insurrection in america like i
needed something
just fun to watch kind of foreign
really classy uh instead of the not
classy
not foreign insurrection we had here
you're getting a lot of love for your
looping love in chat everyone's like
lupin
um and then somebody asked drew gordon
says wow
less viewers than efap and nerd
roddick's friday night tights i wonder
why
is that i think he's saying we don't
have a lot of viewers um
i you know i i'm 50. um
i i don't i stopped worrying about the
size of my dick a long time ago kids
i'm happy anybody shows up to listen to
us talk about our [ __ ] but you do have
to remember
me and mark are middle-aged men
and we're doing a two-hour show where we
just talk to each other
on the internet that's that's not sexy
to a bunch of people
the fact that we get like over a hundred
150 thousand
thousand views every week always
impresses me because i'm like
i wouldn't watch this show like i'd
listen to the show but why the [ __ ]
would i want to watch it two look
looking at two
middle-aged [ __ ] men one of them
always crying about
wanda vision or some marvel [ __ ]
thing the other guy's [ __ ] on
everything
[Laughter]
i'm i'm shocked anyone shows up so thank
you
to the viewers that do show up i'm not
that guy that's like where's everyone
else i'm [ __ ] shocked anybody's here
uh andrew uh chamber chambers is that
the name
i was gonna say you know who else it
impresses native deo thank you my friend
they're not sweating the size of our
audience
they are not they don't sweat the small
things and we got a big thing
so there it's real big native deo
nativedeo.com ladies and gentlemen slash
fat man
uh somebody asked is that kevin smith
club oh andrew chambers says i was
thinking of joining
that kevin smith club today is that
still a thing [ __ ] yeah it's a thing man
join me at that kevin smith club every
week new content and cool cool [ __ ] like
that
um all right what else have we watched
yeah would you been watching quarantine
skyler
uh i watched uh hbo's the outsiders
um but i'm sure that's that's an old uh
conversation
but i really liked it uh it was really
uh i don't know if they're gonna do a
second one but i thought it was great
but i
had are you talking the outsiders yeah
so the jason bateman show that spoilers
wasn't a jason bateman show
like they advertised that so well
because i'm like my boy
it's michael bluth i can't wait to watch
it wait
what and then he was [ __ ] gone and he
was behind the camera he's a hell of a
[ __ ] director
yes that's ozark and he directs this as
well some episodes the outside i thought
he did a really good job
and i enjoyed it but right up until the
last episode
last episode felt very like oh
couldn't agree more they're like we got
we got a finish line it's here
let's make it a demogorgon situation
kind of let's kill everyone in a
shootout god
spoilers everywhere everybody but um
something that i that
i did see uh that i've had the privilege
of seeing this week actually was
uh cherry by the russo brothers which
doesn't uh
come out for a while uh we're talking
about you just you didn't just see the
trailer we all saw the trailer online
but you saw the whole feature
i saw the movie film yes
come out for a few months correct i'm
aware i was uh
i don't know i guess i have like the
same representation as ciara bravo who's
a
star-making performance by the way um
huge fan obviously the russo brothers
they're
kings to me so i was really excited and
then
i i was able to attend they had a
virtual
q a kind of like people are watching us
but it was
it was uh the russo brothers tom holland
sierra bravo the two writers
uh one of them is married to anthony
russo um
and also uh who was hosted by
robert downey jr for no reason
i was like all right he's like yeah you
know and he's like
doing banjo with tom but also like
giving it up to his incredible
performance it was
i felt so lucky to be there it was great
that is really cool what can you tell us
about the movie what are you allowed to
tell us
uh what what is it about it looks like
it's a he turn he goes into the service
and then he turns to
robin banks that's what i got from the
trailer yeah there is a middle part
uh that deals but that is a really huge
threat of the movie which is the opioid
crisis and
uh he and his girlfriend get addicted so
uh he isn't
placed in the present it's it's like a
2017
it's not quite 2019 or even definitely
not 2020
but um but it is amazing uh it's so many
things in one
those guys have such style um they do
some really fun stuff with lighting
and color and uh you know they're
obviously such cinephiles i'm sure it's
homages to other movies but
it really had continuity i mean and and
talk about like
bringing it back to the way
a whole sequence of the film pretty much
a whole act um where
they pulled it in to show the um maybe
claustrophobia or tension
or turmoil of war um so you get a war
movie you get a beautiful coming of age
story about
this one guy and his girlfriend you know
you get uh
and then you get obviously that leading
to darker times when he comes home with
ptsd
drug use and then eventually yeah heists
and all kinds of stuff but it's
done in a real gritty way i mean i won't
say it's like breaking bad but you
feel dirty when you watch it and you
feel his emotional
struggle like he fluctuates wait a few
times tom holland
has major leo early leo vibes in this uh
in this film i think you might see a lot
of critical acclaim and definitely
some sort of nominations for him and the
russo brothers and maybe even sierra
bravo too it's
really good [ __ ] and this is the first
russo brothers
directing since end game right yup this
is the one they picked apparently this
is the one they were kicking around to
tom
on and off he was he they had been
talking about this with
rdj apparently for a really long time
this is something that's really
important to them
um it's set in cleveland which was
personal for the
brothers and uh they just they just
trusted the writers to write it been
shaping it and it's a huge performance
piece and it's
brothers not the least of which of
course because they
you know made some of the greatest
marvel movies of all time and because
they [ __ ]
worked on arrested development and many
other things that i've loved
um but also because they like uh
use their power for good so like they
created this show that was supposed to
be on quibby
called the slugfest that i did like a
voiceover for it's all about comics
history deep dives
like because it was quibby eight-minute
episodes about big moments in comic book
history
the good news is they just announced
like you know quibby went under
all the shows are going to roku so
people are going to be able to watch
slugfest which the the russo brothers uh
produced and put together
with the kids that directed uh um
batman and bill remember that
documentary
yes i do remember that yeah yeah so it's
it's a fantastic
show um and it's it's made with
love clearly nobody was gonna make this
show
unless the russos were like oh we think
this would be great
because it tells the story of comics
beyond behind comics and stuff
so i i i you know not only do i love
what they do
in their day job as directors but i love
the fact that like they used
their juice to create something as cool
as [ __ ] slugfest as well i don't know
when it starts but
you'll be able to watch it on roku
fairly soon and it sounds like cherry
is amazing the trailer i thought looked
really good there was one overhead shot
in the trailer where i was like these
guys are [ __ ] visual stylists and you
forget
because you watch the marvel movies and
you're just like well you know it's
marvel movies so it's got to look like
this but they've got their own style man
it's clearly on display in that trailer
yeah they use their powers for good i
mean you know they have their pick of
anything
and they they used to you know shed
light on this crisis but also just you
know pick this this different thing for
them by the way that overhead shot lasts
quite a while uh so you're gonna really
enjoy that sequence and
um yeah yeah i i think that i i always
love people that get to just do what
they love i mean that's what they earn
but a lot of people don't make those
decisions because there's so many other
masters to serve and monetizing it
so it's pretty dope yeah that's awesome
it's good to hear that sierra bravo is
good she was in
wayne the show that i that i blew up a
couple weeks back
that show was god watched the first
episode that was a dope show so she's
the girl is she the little kid
she's fantastic the one with the thick
masshole accent
she was great uh peter file
69 in chat said uh
charlie cox daredevil just finished
shooting scenes from spider-man 3.
uh we haven't had official confirmation
but kevin fogg you've been doing a bunch
of press
uh in advance of wanda vision last week
once again one of those things where i'm
like
why don't we [ __ ] have him on this
show we if only we applied ourselves
i feel like we're in high school and
then people are always telling me if you
just apply yourself
and we really don't apply ourselves
yeah [ __ ] but anyway he was out there
doing a bunch of press
and people started asking him like hey
man is [ __ ] charlie cox and
spider-man is this this is this this and
you know some questions he
asked answered and some questions he was
very you know
facetious about or something like that
one they were like
you know like when does the phase four
end and he just didn't even [ __ ]
answer them he was just like
yeah so um he uh what was i bringing
that up for oh
charlie cox so apparently
on i don't know why but you assume when
it happens on
twitter there must be some origin to the
truth but i don't know why i
assume that it's probably not but they
said that charlie cox was on set at
spider-man 3
shot and wrapped already wow
who would he be playing if not matt
murdock
um jim murdock
distant president in a world where
they're doing a multiverse
storyline like i don't know do we think
this is how
do we think this is the introduction of
the
tv characters of the netflix characters
to the marvel cinematic universe
i mean it technically doesn't have to be
because they always referenced
the events of the mcu in those shows
even if they didn't do it by name it was
always like oh man you were
here's here's some debris from the
[ __ ] event
that anybody wants to buy or whatever so
it feels like it's in the same universe
they just ignored it
now it looks like they might be like uh
yeah they're here too
i'll give them a little crumb come here
we'll take their devil
luke cage i'm not sure yet we'll talk
yeah
iron fist
i'll totally take there was also another
rumor this week that uh
um what was the other netflix show
um jessica jones that jessica jones
might be popping up in
she-hulk now you know once again
don't see why it can happen makes sense
and it seems like you know kevin feige
now more amenable to
pulling in some of the netflix well now
they've got all the netflix
rights back right the whole reason they
didn't touch him before was netflix
had the daredevil rights for a while but
now everything is back in
marvel's camp so they could do whatever
they want right and it's it's also that
there was a
two-year um
call it a non-compete clause isn't quite
right but it was two years
between the cancellation of those shows
and when those characters could appear
anyplace else you know marvel always
owned them because it was a marvel
tv production but it was that two-year
window
that like officially expired like a
month and a half ago
um buck odie pointed out in uh the chat
this
week there was a story that ran uh where
it was like chris evans is back
as captain america he's in talks with
marvel and then chris evans tweeted
news to me so instantly throwing a
little water on that fire however
there you know the kids in the marvel
movies they ain't always 100 honest with
us are they mark sometimes they like to
be misleading
well we can either do the news or you
can read it in bits and pieces from the
comments
let's do that i forgot we had news to do
take us into the new ladies and
gentlemen
mark bernardin is an old new sound and
he sniffed out some news he's going to
give you the news here's mark bernard
with the news
hey captain america is back what
i had no idea as if this person didn't
tell me in chat
yeah what's the idea is this for real or
as a rumor or what
it does seem to be real at least sources
have told deadline that this is real
and yes it's 100 true that like tatiana
mislani denied being
she-hulk for like six months before she
said oh that's right i'm shihok
because that's what marvel does marvel
disavows knowledge until they're ready
to confirm knowledge
or not even confirm it just say a thing
is true and and move on but yes
it's you know chris evans is dusting the
dust off his captain america uniform
or at the very least the steve rogers of
it all um
to reappear in the mcu not as the star
of his own movies
um much in the way that rdj returned but
not in an iron man movie
like he was back in captain america
movies and back in
in spider-man movies and back in
avengers movies but there were no
iron man movies after iron man 3. and so
i don't know if there will be captain
america movies past
captain america civil war but the
character seems as if he will return
into the mcu
for reals um
it says my internet connection's
unstable so i may be coming in and out
what is the uh what's the upside
to this for the audience wonderful
upside but yes chris evans seemed to be
very like i'm done
like that's finished and i'm happy i did
it but i'm done
what great send off i mean it was a
perfect send-off
and he has been quoted saying that so
many times yeah
he's he seemed very much like i'm that's
behind me and not in a shitty way where
i didn't like it he seemed to love it
but
he was like i'm done i get deposed i
give it the post endgame
spiderman fallout clause you know if
used properly the way
you was i think it could work the
universe wanda is gonna now
open up and to bring it back to one
division so um
they must have a real reason and i think
if he's considering it i'd actually
trust him i i actually believe
from the very little that i've read
about him and know about him
that uh i mean of course money is a
thing but i actually think that you know
he would
he would want to listen to them and um
there must be a real
cool reason let me tell you what i hope
it is i hope they pull him in for
multiverse of madness and i hope he's
the one that has to get to wanda
also by the way there was a total long
period of time where he was aging don't
you want to see 50 year old cap i mean
we went straight from like what
30s to 70s why can't we catch up with
him at some point
there's like 60 years worth of earth
history
that he's around for granted it does
speak volumes they're like hey man
a lot of people got shot while you were
just dancing with your girl
also a word or two also i don't know
terrorism but you know you keep dancing
champ
you know what he earned that break god
damn it he gave
so much for us but like there's there's
there's a hundred percent some story
of what the [ __ ] does captain america do
watching the world fall apart
but can't be kept in america um or
there's the the sort of batman beyond
version of steve rogers
one of the world's greatest tacticians
even at 70
helping to coordinate and plan and you
know be
nick fury for lack of a bitter fury um
you know and maybe he's the [ __ ]
older mentor for a falcon in the winter
soldier maybe he is some
you know gigantic brain for something
that's happening in in phase four phase
five
but the cap old cap who came back and
was like no i'm
gonna tell you about the lady i've been
having sex with and get
shield to sam he wouldn't like that
wouldn't necessarily be the cap we would
get we would get young cap if they were
doing it right like he don't have it's
not like
now you can only have old cap and just
for the story
he came back and was like here's the
[ __ ] shield like
did you either there's no reason it
couldn't be either or both to a certain
degree
i mean i have an idea what if it's
actually because
now hear me out we got wanda building
the multiverse
creating her own realities what if
he becomes you know he goes up in flames
as captain america and turns into the
human torch and he's back for fantastic
four to reprise his role
they're doing all these reprisals i mean
that's rock and roll to me
uh i want to be the thing for that
that's the only chance i have in that
movie because i'm jewish and ben grimm
was jewish so
i would want to keep getting there but
uh i would also just want to see it as a
fan i think that's really um
be absolutely ridiculous you're selling
yourself short scholar you could totally
pull off a sous storm
easily thank you as long as we get the
scene
where johnny storm meets johnny storm
and it's
[ __ ] michael b jordan and chris evans
that's a hey they're doing that with the
spider-man might as well get miles
teller in there
get you know kate spots
that means you could have killmonger
meet the human torch as well
yes now we're getting into x-men world
where can we
there's a lot of actors that are going
to be employed these days
rebecca romain you are coming back
everybody goes to work that's right
speaking of marvel um ethan hawk
has just signed on to join the moon
nightcast
did we lose kev no i'm back sorry my
[ __ ] keeps going in and out
ethan pop moon knight
yes bad guy they're saying but not who
they're not saying
um i don't know that's the only villain
of his that i'm aware of
there's also one called bushman who's a
fellow mercenary who turned on the hero
when the egyptian gold came into the
picture
um there's there's a couple of options
but if he's honshu
that's also super cool um
but it's also [ __ ] cool that ethan
hawk is gonna be a villain in a marvel
tv show
i mean all of these are sentences nobody
thought you'd ever say out loud
he's an incredible unbelievable
incredible actor
i i just don't find it that surprising
that he's in a marvel tv show i think
every actor would love to do it
like because now it's been made so like
cool mainstream
you know by robert downey jr and [ __ ]
like that i don't think
i don't think there's any actor on the
planet maybe daniel day lewis would be
like i ain't doing that
like they come out i'm gonna cobble
instead
i was doing a very bad uh there will be
blood impersonation
of daniel plainview why when was
drinking your milkshake
indeed um what other news we got
i just didn't hear it yeah deadpool
will absolutely be in the mcu and it
will
be a 100 r-rated movie
i mean that's smart and makes absolute
sense
why it if it ain't broke why [ __ ] fix
it and you get even more laughs
by being the r-rated guy in disney world
you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] mickey mouse doggy style it's gonna
be awesome
you know and if there's a world in which
chris evans is returning as captain
america
honestly is there a team up you would
want to see more
than deadpool and captain america
yes deadpool and my dead father because
then he'd be alive again
can i get that crossover mark uh you
have to get the dreaming stone from
wonder woman 84 and then yes you can
have that worked in that movie
i could get a wishing rock ain't nothing
wrong with that
um but yeah i mean feige again to your
point he was doing a lot of
a lot of press um kind of during that
press thing he says yeah no
ryan reynolds is currently overseeing
the script which will be rated r
um and that frankie's very excited to
bring a very different type of character
into the mcu
absolutely that's good news you like it
when people do smart things mark
no it's obvious and yet
sometimes people don't do the obvious
good thing they find ways to do weird
ass
[ __ ] that doesn't make any sense so true
that's why we love kevin feige he is the
only kevin
in the world that matters the kevin who
must be spared at all costs
put him in bubble wrap just make sure
protect that man
indeed um flipping to the other side of
the fence
um let's talk about bc the dc eu
and let's talk about the fact that
martian manhunter is going to be in
zack snyder's justice league yes uh
the actor who um played what the general
character
yes general swanwick harry linux who's
been playing apparently martian
manhunter
the entire time he did play it like that
uh it's the same character
the same dude like in men of steel he's
playing this guy and yeah
like harry lennox is now going to be jon
jones
um and as far as we can tell
has always been so they're going to show
us
their version of jon jones we've seen
the live action version of course for
the last few years on supergirl
and now we're going to see what uh like
the dc
extended universe zack snyder's martian
manhunter is going to look like have we
are there any images yet or no i know he
likes to
put up things on he gives a little cast
chair with a little like you know
twitter but he does some other thing
where he distributes lots of
images and that's where all that snyder
cut info seems to emanate from what is
the
platform he likes vira i think
yeah vero or something like that and
periodically you see stories where
they're like
he showed a picture of of martian
manhunter so i didn't know if there was
any imagery out here
i haven't seen any we're close did i
freeze
and we could hear you but not see you i
did freeze
we could hear you but and you look great
it's a good one to to pause on
yeah it really is it's like sort of like
mildly bemused
yeah well you just popped out of it oh
hey man
sorry my internet's getting unstable by
the second
well it's a great time to talk about
native deo
don't be a liar you know you perspire
oh yeah i'm working on that for
that's producing kid that is running ads
well done
i gotta get asked back that'll get you
asked back
native's gonna send us a a telex or fax
and be like
that skyler kid comes back or we drop
out of the show yeah
but yes harry lennox has shot the the
necessary footage to complete the
character's appearance
um he said that he was or always planned
to be in justice league
but that the schedule was that he was
still shooting blacklist
and zach by the time was going to get
around to it hadn't
left the picture um had sort of bagged
off when shot sweden came in
so you know he's everybody seems
thrilled that they were able to make
this thing happen
that was kind of always planned to
happen oh my god
i keep going out we see you though
you're still here
hey baby
meanwhile
elsewhere in the dc eu um cyborg
as uh ray fisher has found himself um
written out of the flash movie um
i mean and we had we had sort of talked
about this before in the ongoing
coverage of the ray fisher scenario
um but uh yeah just as league actor ray
fisher was offered a cameo role last
june to appear as cyborg and flash movie
um oh hey here he is we're talking about
cyborg
yeah he ain't in the movie no more he's
not in the movie anymore
um although you know and we talked about
it before that he has publicly resigned
from a film
that they decided they didn't want him
in um and so now he's not in
but the the character is being written
out of the of the flash movie entirely
they're not recasting they've just
decided not to go that that that way
um and yeah this this that ray fisher
saga continues
and it it continues to confuse me in
ways
um but also be like totally clear like
here's a dude who has
vast and deep issues with warner
brothers brass
um at large um with joss whedon
specifically
um and and continues to claim
that you know malfeasance was done to
him um
along racial lines um
and so warner brothers have decided that
they don't want to have anything to do
with penny anymore
so i mean i honestly don't know what
more there is to say about the situation
given that
there does not seem to be any new
information coming out
uh it's a bummer overall because clearly
you know
something bad happened he didn't have a
good time on that movie
um and uh whatever they've done they
said they took remedial action or
whatever
still hasn't satisfied ray but um
i don't get it didn't he say a couple
weeks ago that he was like i'm never
gonna make a movie
as long as that guy's there right as
long as walter hamada
remains at warner brothers as they
handle his warner brothers essentially
just go like co-signed or what what was
the story or this week
um yeah basically it was okay that's
cool
um then we're not going to put you in
this movie and in fact there's not going
to be a cyborg in this movie we're just
writing the character out of the flash
entirely
um i mean i'm not uh like you know i
support
um anybody if they feel
you know they've been done poorly by the
system or whatever and i too
have been somebody who's railed against
a studio
from time to time um that being said
i've bitten the hand that feeds as they
say um
that being said it it really does you
know come back
to bite you in the ass like i can't
think of a single time that i
got mouthy with about a studio or bit
the hand that fed where i was like and
then i came out on top
so you know it's it's it's
it's great to have the kind of integrity
where you could be like i don't give a
[ __ ] about the repercussions or what it
does to my career
this is important to be said um or i
need to say this this is my truth or
whatever
but uh it does not help one get employed
that's for sure
no and and i do you know i have sympathy
for ray
and and and i'm i'm here for him
in in to a certain degree but i also
don't really know his specific issues
like he's never actually come out and
said this is what happened to me
you know and so it's it's it's a little
hard to
to to truly just sort of rally the
forces without
this specific remedy that he's looking
for you know it's a bit like
you know hey mr fire person can you come
to my house and they're like is there a
fire it's like you gotta come see
but is there a fire no just just come
real fast
are things on flames just man would you
come to my house
like i just want the data
like tell me the story and you know
because all of this always ends up
working
you know on a a proof basis and b a
narrative basis like tell me what this
story was and tell me how bad it was and
tell me exactly what happened
where on the doll did the bad man touch
you and until
that kind of information comes out um
this always just
feels a lot like he should she said
which
is fine if they stop saying
and just start doing you know but
that is just me that's um i feel bad for
a kid man clearly
like you know he feels that he was done
done wrong um because it's
he's still you know this is still going
on we're still hearing about
this story um so on one hand i'm like
good for him for
like you know he his integrity but on
the other hand it's
i just what happens next
like i hope he gets
more work soon yeah
yeah i hope i hope this was all worth it
yeah for him
um it's a bummer though man like nobody
that's the thing about like [ __ ] when
a movie goes bad or people have a bad
experience like it
you know this is the one place where it
should know it should be fun
you're an adult you get to make [ __ ]
pretend like nobody should ever be
screamed out on a movie set
unless some equipment is falling at them
or some such [ __ ]
and nobody should ever walk away from a
movie feeling like
used abused less than
you know being [ __ ] sad or whatever
the [ __ ] like it's
the greatest scam in the world man where
they're gonna pay you as an adult to
make pretend and do [ __ ] you used to do
as a kid
and it sucks when you know people walk
out of that experience and they have a
bad
time like because honestly i can't think
of a better job in this world
than [ __ ] make it pretend as an adult
it's easy it's [ __ ] fun
sometimes they pay you obscenely to do
so
um you know and i always at least as a
filmmaker i hate when you hear
somebody left a movie and they like oh i
hated it
or it changed my experience or i don't
want to do this [ __ ] anymore
like it should be a it should be [ __ ]
camp for everybody
skyler back me up i couldn't agree more
it's a very privileged job and like
you know i'm not saying anything again
against this specific story but in my
experience you know
the best way to give uh the best way to
hear an actor complain
is to give them a job and like
oftentimes you just
hear people talking about quitting and
drama and things on set and from the
actors perspective i think it's crazy i
mean
um i always maintain or try to maintain
a healthy attitude and when i'm number
one on the call sheet it's like a pretty
joyous place
i think i i think everyone would report
that they had a good time
so i also like um to leave a nice trail
behind me and not to say i'm a brown
noser i just
i i can actually say very confidently
that a lot of people i've worked with
would say yeah i work with that guy
again and like that is
that is a big part of my goal because we
are on this performance-based thing
so when you walk away from something in
an indignant way like that
um you know you have to be willing to
walk away from a lot
and so that is probably why i want the
data because i'm like hey what was this
because like
you know if this was enough to walk away
from we're not no one
you know we all know the opportunity
you're walking away from
it's true it's that's a reason why it
should be taken seriously is because
like
clearly you know most people would be
like hey man shut up like you don't want
to lose a job but it's important enough
for him
to maintain the fight
so to speak yeah just tell the story you
know
speak your truth and if that's the case
then speak all of it
you know and so so that we can
understand you better
you know ray fisher and then we can all
help you make appropriate steps so that
this doesn't happen against anybody else
but without that story
it's hard you know at least for me
to to be able to 100 likes to stand up
besides
behind somebody that i don't know like
if it's somebody that i know and love
and you tell me a bad thing happened
then we will 100
roll out the cavalry to your aid but
independent of any real information it's
just like okay i wish bad things didn't
happen to you but i don't know how we
fix it without knowing what's happening
god forbid it was a situation where
i'm not saying anything apple where josh
sweden was just a bit more of a dick to
him and so
and you know his feelings got hurt and
it just became it fed itself and then
you hear from other people actually he
was the negative one
i'm not saying that's the case but you
know what i'm saying that would really
be a tragedy and that would be like a
very
young mistake i'm sure there have been
situations where something like that has
happened
this you never know he could be so
integral that he's like actually i don't
owe anyone an explanation
um even though there's a big fan base
behind the project this is real life
and like maybe he's taking his efforts
and his talents to creating a piece of
art or a way to tell his story
that's more authentic to him however for
me it's like
the data would only create a ground
swell around that and people could
actually support that decision
i can't imagine to like you know it's
not like the whole town's going to turn
their back on
the kid i i assume that
zach will put him in everything um
they seem to have a tight connection and
the good news is that and we're two
months
away from seeing rey's showcase
you know what i'm saying like the
version of justice league apparently we
were given
hacked most of his stuff out we're about
to see a four-hour version of it where
all of rey's performances
are is going to be reinstated as
originally intended by the director
so there's a chance too that like people
are like holy [ __ ] this guy's great and
all this stuff goes away because they
just want to hire him again you know
what i'm saying like right now
it's people going who's saying this the
guy that was in justice league for like
five minutes but they didn't see
the part as it was intended to be played
they're about to see that
two months from now so maybe things turn
around
for ray so maybe that contributed maybe
that contributed to the way he felt i
mean i know what it's like to be an
actor and get your storyline removed and
you're like what
and even have the director be like it
totally worked we were just long
or like tested really well we just chose
the throw up scene and you're like what
um and uh in this case it sounded so
oddly personal schuyler
you should see this you know that's not
something that i'm exactly referencing
but
um but yeah it's but that's what i'm
saying i mean and then if there was
mistreatment on top of that this isn't
him walking away from the role entirely
right it's just him walking away from
the flash which is not even his own
movie
which maybe doesn't want to work with
that creative team so who knows we might
get
our own standalone movie from him and
this might have been one of the best you
know
side steps to his you know trajectory
fingers crossed what else we got on the
news front mark
uh last item today is uh i will mark
boldly as a rumor it is not reported out
it is not
fact yet it is uh one dude heard a thing
um but the thing is kind of intoxicating
so i won't talk about it
okay the rumor is hbo max
is looking at making a batman the
animated series
sequel that they want to continue that
forward kevin
kevin knows something i don't know what
you're talking about
uh look uh here i'll say this i'm
nobody's saying that i am but i don't
want it to seem like oh he's involved
i'm not involved but i too have heard
this and i've heard this
from very reliable people
well then that's and when i heard it i
freaked out
and i heard this be like i would say a
month before you just said it
so i i think that's real i don't think
that's a rumor i think you could start i
wouldn't say set your watch to it but
like
it's an idea whose time is not only
coming
it's i think it's i think it came and
it's smoking a cigarette
i think that's gonna happen and uh that
how [ __ ] amazing
would that be because you can just
literally pick up
and keep going it's not like oh we gotta
explain why everyone's older it's
[ __ ] animation man
so you can go right back to those
amazing [ __ ] stories those
those stories those scripts the run of
batman uh the animated series
not only changed animation it created
minted a generation of pauldini-like
writers
people who watched that show and said
that's what's possible in this medium
so you got a lot of [ __ ] great
writers to pull from at this point you
know naturally we all hope that they
go back to the brain trust of bruce tim
and paul
deeney and alan burnett you know so
forth and so on
but think about all the people and i'm
not this ain't me throwing my hat in the
ring for a job and [ __ ] like that but
i'm saying
think about all the people who grew up
watching that for the last 20 plus
[ __ ] years
who have become writers themselves how
many writers were made by heart of ice
the episode about mr freeze that paul
wrote and stuff
so i would absolutely [ __ ] i mean
that to me is a no-brainer you got hbo
max you're already doing that amazing
harley quinn show
like that you're printing money if you
go back and do batman the animated
series here
you can't [ __ ] up the legacy that's for
damn sure you know what i'm saying it's
not like
oh they went back and did it again and
now it's ruined like the way some people
felt about twin peaks and [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] it up there's no reason
not to do it as long as you've got the
key creative components
as long as bruce tim is involved wants
to be there
[ __ ] go for it for heaven's sakes man
and they just came out with what was it
batman son of the dragon is that what
it's called
and that was bruce timms right yeah i
believe it was
yeah i because somebody told me about
that a long time ago was the same person
that also told me about
the animated btas reboot potential
so i ain't saying like it's done and
contracts have been signed but like
somebody who i know who knows these
things
like gave me the the whole [ __ ]
you know are you serious they're like oh
yes so
we got a [ __ ] happy future uh ahead
of us man the 2021
is the year of masters of the universe
i'm going to claim that [ __ ] right now
for me and mark
2022 i feel like that will be the year
of batman the animated series the return
that would be fantastic yeah you know
and and whether it's
you know bruce tim i hope he was
involved or could be involved or not
but to your point there's a generation
of storytellers who were influenced by
that show
who could come to it with that mixture
of reverence
and and and sort of discovery
that can absolutely be in the spirit of
while being a new thing entirely and
still absolutely join up at the end of
that train
and continue on those stories and you
still have a mark hamill
mayor and i want to do the joker you
still have a kevin conroy who may or may
not want to come back and do batman
and it can just fall back into place and
that would be amazing to see why
wouldn't mark pamela do it i feel like
he does it for
like hobbies on twitter these days
i mean he he you know is
having just spent time with him as
skeletor
um the man is incredibly [ __ ] gifted
um and can really
do voiceover in his sleep however
he refuses to sleep he's wide awake and
giving you
110 he don't execute the dude constantly
elevates i can't imagine
if they're like we're getting the old
gang back together we're on a mission
from god
that he don't jump in with both [ __ ]
feet man like
we're living in a day and age where this
kind of [ __ ] is possible where like
something you know when it was done he
thought they were done and then all of a
sudden they were like hey how about some
video games and they're like oh all
right and then that blew up into
something huge too
but now they got the chance to like just
go back and
do it all again make more i can't
imagine him or kevin would say no
and i mean scrape away everything else
they got that [ __ ] hbo max money man
you know like what are they gonna say no
to that no way
so yes fingers crossed that would be
nice that'd be amazing i i i'm
you know what if i'm a betting man if
that was in the markets if i played the
stock markets and that was a potential
stock to buy
i'd buy heavily in batman the animated
series reboot i think that's gonna be a
reality
that's all the news mark that is all the
news my friend give it up for mark
bernard ladies and gentlemen he
he brought you the news you are now up
to date for heaven's sakes you know
everything that's going on in this here
world of pop culture and whatnot
um after a very long show and a very
weak internet connection i'm probably
gonna
bail without doing questions um we we
have been at this for like two hours and
uh
i'm a little frustrated by how i'm
getting kicked off my internet
uh but uh before we get out of here
big [ __ ] round of applause for the
dude who not only came
gave us content talking about [ __ ]
spring awakening and gave us a [ __ ]
early cherry review and stuff
uh but sat with us throughout the whole
[ __ ] show man and was never dead
weight man you were
welcome back any [ __ ] time give it up
for skyler well done sir
appreciate that yeah have you back any
time especially when i'm in quarantine
you know you got nothing to do when uh
when can they watch the tv show what is
it called again there's no
zoe's extraordinary playlist you could
call it infinite playlist just not when
you're searching for it um
zoe's extraordinary playlist is every
tuesday at 8 00 p.m
we've had we're about to be three
episodes into season two but um
yeah some wild [ __ ] um i do a jekyll and
hyde type of musical number this past uh
episode where i'm going in between songs
and like you know glitching so it's
it's a real fun show what was your
favorite song to cover so far
uh i did uh we we actually did the amer
the entire american pie as one seven
minute warner
uh we have like the choreographer of la
la land and like all this really great
stuff mandy moore
and uh yeah it's just like it's really
artfully done a lot of steadicam shots
so
um um personally i did uh i think i love
you in the pilot
proclaimers i i would walk 500 miles so
we kind of cover it all
but i'd say that sequence was pretty
incredible how can i man
right now um
ladies and gentlemen this show is made
possible by a grant from the helena
rubinstein
no not for helen rubicon good folks at
native d.o
deodorant ladies and gentlemen
nativedeo.com
is where you can go to buy their fine
products so you could smell pretty
uh and get fresh uh native makes
incredible [ __ ]
you tell them fat man sent you at
checkout they're going to give you 20
off if you're into that sort of thing
but if you really like the company
you say [ __ ] the discount just give them
their whole hundred percent that's what
i do
all the time anytime then company tries
to give me a discount i say
i'm paying double that's not true but uh
they're great company they've supported
our show go to nativedeo.com
right now there is no show without the
guy who's
right above me man give it up for mr
marvelous mark bernard
and ladies and gentlemen always a
pleasure my friend
uh and the man who makes it all happen
the man
uh in the chair our own uh our own ned
leeds if you will ladies and gentlemen
give it up for jc jc pop on and say
hello
how's the kid uh kitty's good she slept
ten and a half hours last night
[ __ ] mutant huge she doesn't nap
though
so like nights are good days are really
intense
she's probably [ __ ] terrified because
she sees that taunton skull
moment of her life
um thank you to everyone for uh was it
two weeks ago we did jc's birthday show
you guys were very nice
uh and gave him some love that means the
world to us because without him we ain't
got nothing going on
so thank you for hanging out ladies and
gentlemen we will be back
saturday boys feels like saturday again
saturday
we'll be back on set probably earlier
time yeah we can do 4 p.m
i was i don't know what i'm allowed to
say i was recording uh
the hollywood reporter
uh actors roundtable today well well
well look at that
whipping out your i know famous yeah
well done my friend
um yeah so we pushed a little bit this
week next week on saturday
we'll get back together at four o'clock
and uh of course
uh four o'clock uh pst seven o'clock est
and we'll be talking about the third
and possibly most revelatory episode
of one division yet but until that time
ladies and gentlemen
um for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernardin i'm skylar aston
uh tune in next time same
fat time j.c you can say your name i'm
jc
i saw you like he was moving toward the
mic and he was like i guess i don't get
to do it
tune in next time same fat time ladies
and gentlemen same fat
channel smodcasts.com or youtube.com
kevin smith uh uh
wakanda forever ladies and gentlemen
peace
you